the way podcast clips work is kind of
crazy man you take something that might
be out of context you give it a sexy
salacious title to make it extra juicy
and maybe that's not fair but hey who
cares my friends from athletic grand
said go for it yeah so thanks to
athletic greens for bringing you this
juicy bit
like did tick tock's the [ __ ] that's
just [ __ ] and i'm enjoying watching you
guys and it's it's i love taking people
people like to say that we like
people like to like say that we kiss
each other and stuff like that
no i i've not heard that
you didn't see that no no what do you
mean you guys kiss each other no no we
don't kiss each other of course but we
but we play around we play around with
their heads and we say that we kiss each
other
okay like on a duet or something so
i'll be like okay i'll kiss him for a
million likes dude like okay we want to
see that i don't know why they just
i don't know why they want to see two
twins kiss but i mean i guess it gets
them they might turn them on
the uh
the the kissing thing i don't know
anything about that i haven't heard
anything it's not gonna it's not going
to happen it's just a little side thing
that's it if you go to
athleticgreens.como
you get
five of these travel packs for free and
i don't go anywhere without my travel
packs plus you get an immune supporting
entire year supply of vitamin d
and you just try it because it is so
tasty and delicious it's just a great
way to start your day and to get all the
nutrients and vitamins that you need i'm
telling you athleticgreens.com
stevo for five of these packets and a
whole year's supply of vitamin d
and wait until it tastes how delicious
it is and what an epic way to start your
day so yeah dude thank you athletic
greens